je dis est ce que toi tu as déjà une
rupture difficile dit nous tous à nous
mêmes quand et voilà même à l'école -
comme ça comment il s'appelait ton
premier amoureux j'aime bien ça voilà la
première
j'avais 5 ans non c'est 5 ans ouais cinq
ans mais c'était très plate sawi genre
vous tu m'aimes oui non elle n'a même
pas c'est l'ensemble qui s'appelait
comment s'appelait jadis appelée belin
bolloc'h béni stabili
[Rires]
gâteau ça va un petit monde de la rue
avec qui j'ai joué et je ne sais pas ce
qui est devenu jacques belin mais dans
mes pièces d'ivresse notamment
mais c'est un koala et chaque boulon est
avec rackers pour lui
qu'il ne peut pas coller voyez il est
mis des minots il a peut amener un petit
peu cassé c'est mignon pour
assécher pactisent avec chaque bol en
métropole qui nous regardent
doit être dans son usine est en train de
voir des détracteurs
il est à la retraite maintenant non non
il bosse tout court je connais ces gars
là ont tous fait plutôt des fous et
pépito il connaît bien pépito
[Rires]
pourquoi je te demande pas pourquoi je
te demande ça la lousiane rien et au
hasard jacques et là j'ai décidé de
faire une surprise ce tract il
ah oui et non arrête ou non non jacques
chacon josiane oui bien surprise pour
toi il était d'accord mais je t'aide pas
manquer est venu pour toi mais cette
personne est entièrement habillé en mode
ce qui rapport au chalet à gstaad non
il va falloir que tu découvres qui se
cache dans la combi ce que je verrai pas
la tête il a une cote ni cagoule oui à
tout il est vendu les libéraux il est
méconnaissable la surprise ne peut pas
de paris tu dois lui poser des questions
mais elle ne peut répondre que par oui
ou par non de la tête ah oui c'est
quelqu'un qui est très mobile de la tête
déjà cet indice est un a dit je te
laisse
trop je gagne 5000 euros parmi nos
[Applaudissements]
attentions
fait rentrer la surprise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr très surprise et à la merci
surprise tu peux te connais tu déposes
les attentions qui est la surprise c'est
moi je commente les questions oui alors
la surprise était là et elle un homme
alors là a priori si c'est une femme
c'est un homme il fera tout mouillé nom
de l'atp we dance mais surprise la
surprise me connais tel depuis longtemps
ah bah oui et surprise hôtel me faire
chanter
la cerise noire parce que la surprise à
chaud
la surprise à télé jouer avec moi non
non
la surprise est fait elle partie de la
fête c'est un métier de spectacles ce
qu'elle fait un métier de spectacle oui
est-ce qu'elle travaille sur don non sur
les films
à que ça et elle est payée pas connu
pour ça en tout cas je suis très fan de
la surprise vous connaissez les rageux
l'adorent sais pas si c'est parce que
j'ai demandé de qualifier la surprise et
d'artistes oui ah bah oui oui oui
cependant est-ce que la surprise chante
non mal
les assauts qui chante mal j'en ai mais
je vous dis là surprise
je suis on kiffe sur la surprise c'est
un de mes gars préférées
oui il est alors moi c'est voilà c'est
un des plus d'arcade du moment mais
vraiment vraiment vraiment
josiane je donne un indice grand
humoriste à cette surprise a déjà fait
un défilé de mode ouais
ouais c'est tout
cette surprise est une star des réseaux
cette surprise tu l'aimais énormément
surprise à chaud cette surprise a de
plus en plus chaud cette reprise rapide
est retrouvé
sur place rappelle mathias sombrer
[Applaudissements]
les gallois
c'est un bosseur
merci
vas-y se contente de voir mourir tu sais
pas comment je te kiffe bragg narre le
breton pour moi c'est c'est celui qui me
fait le plus brillant
alors si toi mon chéri ça va mon chéri
écoutent oui c'est un peu long et
là tu es content très content et
s'écrase jouer l'atuge exactement à
l'européen mercredi à mater leurs 30 à
partir du 5 octobre fragonard le breton
peut saboter je suis fou de toi qu'est
ce que tu me fais rire josiane raconte
nous un mois j'ai connu j'ai connu
enfant c'est ça oui ça a eu mon fils on
t'avait quel âge 15 16 ans et 17 18 7
voilà c'est ça il t'a moins musclé a
révélé moins musclées aux coûts plus
qu'on sait
gérer pas jusque là parce que tu es
garder un niveau quand même assez
mais c'est vrai que ça peut évoluer mais
et donc après j'ai tu devenu ringard
ragueneau et voilà mais je connais bien
son fils qui est c'est comme un frère
c'est ça qui j'embrasse très fort ce
soir une grosse paire qui nous regardent
josiane t on tant de loi mais les gens
qui savent bien que si je dis balance
des claques moyens
d'agir
[Applaudissements]
ce
qui m'avait demandé
si
[Rires]
tranquille
j'avais
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais attendez ça fait partie de ceux-là
c'est le jeu et racket c'est gentil mais
j'ai
l'habitude des îles des antilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bâle est demandé avant
sa mort
chaque signe d'amitié oui très bientôt
très douce et très
[Rires]
intéressés il n'y a pas un film tu as
fait tu as passé un fan alors le sait
peut-on cours web voir ce qu'elle est on
là on voit chez envie de te voir au
cinéma ça a été un amoureux incroyable
qu'est ce que tu me fais rien merci de
majorer moi je suis je sais que tout le
monde te la dit ces cas là beaucoup de
tonic j'étais fan de toi tu as des
masses non
agir oui bah oui j'ai à te l'a dit et
c'est vrai que voilà j'adore ce qu'il
fait tu me tues me tue de rien j'avais
beaucoup et c'est un amour et josiane tu
le suis tu le suis mais oui bien sûr ils
viennent à la maison on bouffe et le
soir de cet art art
il disait ce que tu veux qu'on te ramène
un truc là
c'est la face à la maladie